[Music]
all right let's take one more let's go
to adam in
phoenix hey adam what's up brother hey
dr delaney how are you
i'm good brother what's going on man uh
so the reason i'm calling today
is my 30 year old brother was recently
in a car accident
um and due to the car accident he
is now paralyzed from the waist down no
man sorry man i'm so
sorry so so sorry it's heartbreaking man
yeah yeah um so the first four weeks
after the accident
you know he was in the hospital um
having surgeries and
therapies and you know learning how to
live with
what's now his new life
is this permanent paralysis
the doctors think yes but you know
there's always
hope or miracles or whatever the case
might be
sure but the prognosis is this is not
temporary this is a
a new permanent way of being correct
okay okay yeah so who's he staying with
now
so he's actually living with my parents
now because
uh he has a girlfriend but you know he's
not married or anything
so yeah my parents thought it'd be best
that he moves back in with them okay
sorry man i'm so sorry so how can i help
brother what can i
do for you so since he's come back
you know i've flown out there shortly
after he moved back with my parents just
to visit see how he's doing
you know try to normalize things a
little bit or help him
or help my parents in any way i could
but since i've left and come back home
since i actually live in arizona
you know just talking with my parents
and kind of talking with him
there's been you know anger and
fights between them and um you know
wishes he would have just died in the
car accident stuff like that
so i guess my question is how can i help
from so far away when i'm hearing this
from them you know i try to talk to my
brother
text him call him you know sometimes he
does respond sometimes he doesn't and i
think it's kind of like
some days are better than others
essentially so
man um so not my
brother but my oldest friend on planet
earth um
was in a similar situation the weekend
after he graduated college
um one of his friends ran a stop sign
and he's been wheelchair-bound ever
since
and with some traumatic brain injury and
so
um i remember the arc of
this i think i think he was 19 or 20.
he's probably 21.
um yeah he changed everything changed
everything
right a couple of things that i learned
from that situation just
personally is man really what you're
talking about
i took everything personally especially
the first year or two
um i mean i remember visiting my buddy
in um the rehab hospital
i mean he didn't know what day it was
didn't know what time it was
yet i took every glance every
dismissal every angry statement that he
would mumble out i took all that stuff
personally man and
i didn't realize the extent of the
trauma inside his body
right um i did not ex understand the
extent of grief his
mom and dad were going through um his
little brother still one of my best
friends in the world i didn't understand
the grief his brother was going through
right i'd understand the grief i was
going through so
the first thing i would tell you is be
real gracious with
everybody there is not a right way to go
through with this
um feeling suicidal after you lost
what feels like everything is is is not
out of bounds
i don't say it's normal but it's not
crazy okay
um not knowing what to do not wanting to
talk to people being embarrassed being
ashamed
uh is he able to go to the bathroom on
his own does someone have to help him
with that
uh he is able to go to the bathroom on
his own but you know
my parents help you know clean up and
you know after the fact
yeah yeah so all of that is is a level
of discomfort
and embarrassment and shame all that
stuff
and then your parents they they had a
life
right and i know the cool thing is to
say like i'll do anything man i had a
life and i got a 30 year old
living with me 30 year old who takes a
lot of work and then they are going to
get cast into
who's going to take care of him after
we're gone and do we have enough
money and we have to remodel the house
there's all these practical things
that yeah just come out as anger anger
is a normal part of the grieving
process it's it's wired into us it's
okay
so the best thing you can do for them is
and for everybody is one be really great
graceful
right be really gracious number two
keep reaching out man keep reaching out
write letters send funny things
keep reaching out if they call you and
they're angry and frustrated
if you can at any shape form or fashion
put them on facetime so you can see
them they can talk to you um and just
let them talk man
just let them talk it's part of the
grieving process they are heartbroken
their whole worlds have been turned
upside down
all y'alls have right um
man and here's where you will get
eventually
if not sooner or later i'll never forget
sitting in an ihop
it's me my best friends chris
and caleb who was ryan's little brother
and we had a talk like are we gonna like
we made fun of each other a lot
uncomfortably so um
people would ask like are you all
friends that's just how we talk to each
other we've known each other since we
were zero right
um we talked and we had like man we're
not gonna treat him any different
right if i have to go you know help him
in the bathroom
it's gonna be uncomfortable for both of
us and so we're gonna laugh our way
through this
and or if i'm gonna you know we're gonna
have to get the chair out when we're
going to eat um get a wheelchair out and
we're going to eat or going to concerts
but
man we're going to do some fun we're
going to make some fun of each other a
lot and he does it
back really uncomfortable for me man
um and he makes me embarrassed and i
don't get embarrassed for so all i have
to say is this
at some point you're gonna have to
reintroduce
humor brotherly love poking at each
other
bring that back in due time and that
will help
norm this the psychological and
spiritual connections that y'all have
right
he's obviously going to have a different
life because of mobility challenges
one of the hardest things about mobility
challenges is everybody treats you
differently like you're somehow
gentle and broken and there's something
just
compassion about saying nice face
nice shirt that's how you haircut that's
what you're gonna do right
and you suddenly realize oh you're just
one of the guys does that make sense
and so it's not handling him with kid
gloves that may not be the season right
now a few weeks out
right there's still a lot of healing
going on um
but over time you want to be the brother
you were beforehand
right the one that loves him and that
pokes at him and that clowns them about
christmas and
all those fun things that brothers do
and those mean things brothers do
that's going to be a key part of him his
healing and his growth does that make
sense
yep yeah definitely and then here's a
big one man and i did not do this for
years i didn't even know to do it
but you're going to be grieving from
this too
suddenly things got really mortal right
how old are you
32 32. are you married kids anything
yep married uh one daughter okay
everything
in your psychology just changed the
yeah it could always be worse you know
that kind of nonsense the trivial stuff
that moms you know
sew onto pillows that's real in your
world now
you know what that looks like and it
will
come out and how you parent it will come
out in how
you when your wife is 15 minutes late
calling you
you'll immediately go to those the worst
case scenarios
you'll it'll change what you drive it'll
change the way you interact people
it will change you and so i want to make
sure you
take care of your grief make sure you're
whole man and if that means go to see
somebody go see somebody if that means
you gotta get with a local group
in your hometown get with a local group
in your hometown
if that means being honest and letting
your wife know hey
i'm still struggling with this big time
let her grieve cause she's gonna be
grieving too
your wife your daughter and her uncle
right all everybody's gonna be grieving
this thing if you skip the grief part
and try to start solving things man
you're just going to shove it down and
i'm telling you i did that and i didn't
deal with it for
years and i didn't know where all of my
angst and drama and relational issues
were coming from and a lot of it stemmed
back to
oh my gosh man my oldest friend in the
world somebody i loved
dearly just like a brother
one weird turn and it all changed right
so don't dishonor yourself make sure
you're taking care of yourself too
thank you so so much for that call man
thank you so so much for that call
if you're in a season um where you can
sit down and read
again i've recommended this book a
million times um finding meaning
by david kessler it's about grief it's
often about death but this is grief as
grief is grief man there's no you can't
compare it
um it's a great book to to sit down and
read
when your parents are ready to start
reading it's a great book to read as a
family
y'all can talk about it you can think
about it but it'll give you some
practical tools
but more importantly it will let you
know you're not crazy
there is no right way to grieve there
isn't wrong ways but there's no right
way to do it
continue to show up there for your
family man let him be angry let him be
frustrated let him be heartbroken
if your brother says hey i'm going to
kill myself today obviously called 9-1-1
right but him waking up frustrated and
just beat down by this
is normal man and you too all right
thanks so much for that call adam
sucks man suck suck suck sucks brings
back a lot of
man